Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is going to be absolutely amazing.
Earlier, we had some delightful discussions
on synthesizing sound from animations.
The input would be a sequence, for instance,
a video depicting the complete and utter destruction
of plates, wooden bunnies, or footage of bubbling
water.
And the output should be a physical simulation
that yields appropriate sound effects for
the observed phenomenon.
In short: input, animation, output, synthesized
sound effects for this animation.
And, get this!
What if we would turn the problem around,
where we have sound as an input, and we try
to synthesize an animation that could create
such a sound.
Mmm, I like it, a very spicy project indeed.
And however crazy this idea may sound, given
the richness of sound effects in nature, it
may actually be easier to generate a believable
animation than a perfect sound effect.
It is extremely difficult to be able to match
the amazingly detailed real-world sound of,
for instance a sliding, rolling or bouncing
bolt with a simulation.
The more I think about this, the more I realize
that this direction actually makes perfect
sense.
And, no machine learning is used here, if
we look under the hood, we'll see a pre-generated
database of rigid body simulations with dozens
of different objects, and a big graph that
tries to group different events and motions
together and encode the order of execution
of these events and motions.
Now hold on to your papers, and let's check
out the first round of results together.
Wow.
I think it would be an understatement to say
that they nailed it.
And what's more, we can also add additional
constraints, like a prescribed landing location
to the object to make sure that the animations
are not too arbitrary, but are more in line
with our artistic vision.
Crazy.
As I am looking through the results, I am
still in complete disbelief.
This shouldn't be possible.
Also, please don't get the impression that
this is all there is to this technique.
There are a lot more important details that
we haven't discussed here that the more curious
Fellow Scholars could be interested in...
discrete and continuous time contact events,
time warping and motion connections.
There are tons of goodies like these in the
paper, please have a look to be able to better
gauge and appreciate the merits of this work.
Some limitations apply, such as the environment
is constrained to be this plane that we've
seen in these animations, and as always with
works that are inventing something completely
new - it currently takes several minutes,
which is not too bad, but of course, there
is plenty of room to accelerate the execution
times.
And some bonus footage!
This will be just spectacular for creating
music videos, animated movies, and I am convinced
that professional artists will be able to
do incredible things with such a tool.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!